okay for people joining this livestream
we are talking about language
completeness and consistency our a
weekly meeting I think it the weekly
meeting um and we've got a variety of
topics operators for operator wrong
right so III should guide you through
this one so obviously there are a lot of
sessions here and we probably should
spend a little bit of time discussing
each one but the mmm so right we have
this new feature in 12.1 where like if
you do write f triple at X and then you
hover over to triple add you get write a
little thing that tells you oh that's
apply and gives you a that's really cool
yes I I remember I remember vaguely
talking about this feature ages ago okay
right and so I mean we don't want to put
them on every single operator like if we
put them on plus and what the heck is
postfix that doesn't make any sense
all right that in fact that's exactly
what I say right in in my note so if you
put slash slash into the Help Center it
will take you to postfix but of course
postfix is a formatting wrapper that
formats things in that sort of postfix
notation
yeah that's bonkers right so either we
need to I don't know if you need it's
just a separate page or - just a note
add a note that there's also this
special input form which is myopic it
should go no look I think this
particular case mm-hmm it could also go
to the operator input forms tutorial
which had lists all of them or maybe we
need a new page for it I don't know let
me think about it for a second okay so
um the most useful thing to see here
would be something like in parens not in
the same font as this or not necessarily
impress but in italics or something
postfix notation yeah something like
that postfix notation might be a good
thing to call it postfix function now it
should be noted here that the reference
that you're getting is the same thing
that you would get if you open help
viewer and type in slash slash no this
is completely bumpkin see ya so it makes
sense or actually it doesn't go it
doesn't direct hit the post fix but it
only pulls up one result which is
postfix so yeah whatever we do it makes
sense to kind of fix it everywhere right
and we also have this so we have this
name know I had a problem with prefix
postfix and with infix alright look I
think what we should do is just call it
is there anything that would break if we
just made dedicated pages for these
operators dedicated function home pages
with what name well that's that's part
of why I asked my question is right we
could call them like slash slash at and
I mean yeah I mean maybe we can
synthesize a name that isn't well the
word the name construct is in a sense at
sign could be documented on the
constructed page I mean they could both
be documented on the construct page but
they're not in fact construct that's the
point they're not rent and if you held
them they wouldn't be construct exactly
I mean I think it's useful conceptually
to have standalone pages
to these guys I suppose the other
possibility as we could create character
pages for these characters is there any
reason why character pages have to have
well I guess it's don't have a long name
but yeah especially slash slash doesn't
have a one name hold on let's think
about no it doesn't have a long name
that's the point um okay look this is a
special case I don't think we should try
and build a general system for it let's
just figure out what the best thing to
do in the special case is by the way can
somebody please comment that the slashes
in this page of the wrong font they look
a long fun to me yeah I can make okay so
the question is what do you want this to
do what will be the most useful thing
for this to do so imagine something more
real we've got blah blah blah blah blah
slash slash matrix form or something you
know what I'm saying and you see that in
a piece of code
look I think the most useful thing to do
would be to say postfix function
application although that's very
technical well it I mean it doesn't
really matter what what you call the
well I mean I suppose we have to have
some text here but I mean in my view the
more important the more important point
is where does the I go to which is the
help problem well if we even have an i
what about if this one okay what would
the mode look that really the point is
you don't need a big essay on this all
you need to know is this is equivalent
you know what would we like it to say
let's imagine that what it could say
this is the fun what do you
fundamentally want to see there you
fundamentally want to see you know is f
of X that's what you that's what you
need to know that's the big long
beginning and end of what you need to
know that's true so you know sending you
to a page to go discover this fact is
some how about we could say just have
that text right there you know X you
know stylized
X slash F is f of X zone and then the
same thing for prefix and infix based on
not greater precedence people might want
to know actually how far the matrix form
extends where there my well I don't I
don't think we do that let that be
greenery so display yeah yeah if you
look up slash at it'll take you to map
and I don't think map says anything
about precedence at all you have to
actually look up the precedence table
Oh sir it's its own different issue I
mean to mention that on those pages the
precedents but honestly we are now
solving the precedence problem with
these UX things and I just don't think
it's some
okay so let's just think what this do we
have anybody from design here could we
try and um the mom we do not because we
weren't planning to tuck on any designee
things today but maybe Devon can get
someone Steven a live streamis is saying
that really wants to explore the nuances
of these operators but these this one is
very unused it really is just the same
as this um
it's literally just right if you did
hold complete of X slash F and then hit
that with whole full form Utes or even
without full form right you just get f
of X yeah it's really nothing more than
a syntactic I wonder if the word is is
the right word becomes technically its
parses - but that may be too technical -
technical is interpreted as long too
long that's good good good concept
though is equivalent to as interpreted
as is better if we can get that to work
graphically that's what I think we
should do and I think that for now we
should not ayat to anywhere I think in
the you know the page the precedence
page which this isn't
but operator precedence yeah this is a
kind of I mean this is a thirty-year-old
tutorial which I guess has been kept up
to date it's at least partially up today
because it's such a major pain to update
yeah
I mean I think I think it's definitely
completed with respect to ASCII
operators I'm sure there are unicode
operators which are me yeah yeah I mean
Unicode operators generally are dealt
with here but as far as ASCII operators
is concerned eating and I consider this
Canon and any variation between this in
front-end or Colonel behavior is
automatically a bug and often quite a
serious one to know I mean one day this
page should get reformatted one nicely
but it's not terrible right now
well I wouldn't complain about that
because it's a huge pain in the butt to
make changes to as well why because you
have a grid with like a hundred and
fifty rows and you know dividers and
random places so if you add or delete
anything you have to very very very
carefully count rows and then adjust the
true-false and doctor Tools has no
tooling okay but maybe we should turn
this into a series of cells so that we
don't have that problem and just format
it as a stack of cells that could be
done mm-hmm um and just you know for
example putting that as a caption
underneath that was good when it was in
a book 30 years ago it's really not the
right place for it now you know I think
we should just list you know I mean this
should just have a minor refactor and it
can be retooled in terms of the way it's
entered which would help things and so
on
yeah this page is not the most
attractive in terms of just the pure
look of it um okay um you know we're the
guys who are commenting on things on our
live stream I I would like to say that
in the new version da da da da look at
that and that beautiful it explains what
it is so the only thing we were having
trouble with is the ones that don't have
a function version um I think this is
really nice to be able to do this okay
I think we should try and do this as
interpreted as f of X we should do um X
tilde F tilde Y is interpreted as and we
should just try and style this to look
as good as we can okay makes sense
um okay the next item so yeah the next
one I think right these are you know you
know I'm not right we right we gave one
definition of not too common which is
you won't see them an input form and
that's clearly literally wrong I think
but so here are a bunch more I think
these should be add Oh what is the issue
the issue the issue is should there be a
raft at all absolutely why wouldn't that
be wrong well because if you have a raft
on every plus and minus its first of all
it's silly and second of all it can
actively you know right okay so the
question is the question is you know
it's kind of like used to play enough
lifeboats on the ship you know who
doesn't get a raft right I think the
answer is things where the notation
is absolutely standard in in so let's
just look at the operator precedence
table and I can write so I have so I
have a list there of what we currently
give what is missing and you know may be
worthwhile okay so these should
definitely all every single one of these
should be rafted okay and they're in the
all are right so fine then the next
section is also things which are
currently rafted pattern is tricky
because it could be optional but because
it doesn't know whether it's optional or
whether or not no it doesn't and right
now it currently refs as pattern always
which is probably the better thing to do
but I mean couldn't we do that in this
case that's a pattern and that's not a
pattern that's an optional surely we can
do that correctly right that's actually
misleading right but if it's be blank :
C with no a call and then it's suddenly
yeah well as we know that syntactically
well well the colonel knows this because
it can parse the whole expression and
and and knows my point of view is my
point of view about this is we really
have to get this right
I mean well I mean yeah so you have to
appreciate the only thing the front end
understands is you know it knows how to
scan operators it understands precedents
and it understands associate ippity okay
well what is that structure
they've got built that well that that C
that's that has nothing what that but
that has nothing to know with what the
front end knows about the colonel took
that raw Robox which is a flat row box
flat ternary row box and and turned it I
don't know if you want to see the
associativity you know triple click on
one of the colons so that captured
everything now triple click on the other
one
I'm not a very good triple clicker it
captured everything again right okay so
it's being treated simply as a flat
operator I see so the box's level that's
flat yes I um that's messy so I mean
this is honestly a bug that it says that
this is I mean look honestly I think we
got a scan for the obvious cases and try
and do this we just got our heuristic to
do this and do the best we can and try
to not say it's pattern where it's
actually going to be optional okay I
think the alternative is we have links
to both no no no that's just us wimping
out we know which it is I mean this is a
computer izybelle thing which it is
let's try and invent a heuristic if the
heuristic if we're not sure leave it
blank just don't put anything there for
now but I'm sure we can resolve this as
at the front at the level of the front
end I mean it's not that complicated of
syntax we've got the whole syntax for
this list right here it's right right
right well no it isn't right here um I
mean I can try try to make this work
it's I think it's not I mean I mean you
you say it's not that complicated of a
syntax but what happens if you have a :
b : c : d and i mean that unambiguously
parses to something but you know the
rules are tricky who that's not what i
was expected
look this is the corner case try to do
the best you can to get to give the
right indication and don't give any
indication if you're not sure okay
right so if we think these all belong
there absolutely they will belong most
definitely then we should also add
pattern tests to that list which people
may or may not be in my next section of
ones which don't currently have refs but
okay that two-way rule absolutely needs
a rock okay what about increment and
decrement hell yes okay I mean you only
know those if you happen to know CEO
something well no no it's not one
Operator that's two operators yeah free
incremental well listen it's the same
story as in the colon case okay this is
not the most important thing in the
world okay okay but let's try to get it
right if we can if we think that look
realistically I mean I mean if it's a
guy who's from you is get it right or
don't put it up that's something we can
implement you know very quickly
yeah that's we find by me I think in
this case of increment I would suggest
let's see increment is the post case
right pre increment is there yeah and
look this one I mean that's right I mean
this one should be doable right cuz it
should be able to tell it's doable by
the front end it's just that you know
you have to add yet more checks and yet
or cases that okay listen what I would
do in this one for the time being for
this version just bring up increment and
decrement and don't worry about the pre
increment pre-decrement case you're
close enough to know that it's increment
it means you're not thinking it's you're
not thinking it's some you know string
join or something make sense okay so I I
would say that one we could have it be a
bug for the time being that doesn't know
that it's pre increment - before - way
rule I see absolutely no excuse for not
bringing that one up why isn't that one
we up I mean it's not just an oversight
or well well well you have to
distinguish between the two a virile
character and the esky Eska fide to a
role I mean they're both missing but
okay the occupied one I'm less concerned
about than me because in a notebook it's
gonna turn into this basically right but
we typically okay so let's make sure
this one works but the other one that is
important is undirected edge things like
that okay those are on my list so so why
don't we go through my list and we can
define upset delayed that's the kind of
worms yeah so I guess we don't have tag
set and we don't have I mean we don't
also have you know clear which might be
useful
am i only nice to have clear would be
very nice to have this one um couldn't
we at least do the : / : part of this
dad it'd be pretty straightforward let's
do it let's not worry about the other
part I mean in the other part if we say
that the other part is define or
whatever that that I think we'll live
with that
yeah / : direct hit direct hits in the
healthy or anything that direct hits in
the health viewer is very trivial for us
to add alright fun do it and don't worry
about the fact that this I mean again
please list it as a bug which at some
point we should think about but I don't
think it's the most important thing
immediately to get the colon colon
equals part of this correct okay okay
right so these are currently arrested
guys I think they're pretty anyone ISM
there's no way to not rock them nobody's
gonna know what they are right I mean
you know they might if they you know if
they know logic notation they'd know not
if they know some I think we invented
these notations so they're not so are is
and an or not they're I think those
should also be there I thought I should
be robbed it and a notion of course be
rafted yeah I thought
I thought they were on the list maybe
but ok well we'll fix those right and so
then I have sort of two two sections
with I mean can I can I ask a question
here about about things that don't
things like circle plus that um you know
the unev al u ated operators right so if
you looked at my there are principles
principle two says that once without the
built in wooden don't get dressed okay
hold on which are two common which are
not too common right so I'm okay yeah
right okay fair enough that's a good
that's a good criterion so which ones
are so accompli slopped rafted no I
think it should be what's the first of
all it's not an operator it's not the
operator it's not it's a it's an operand
operand or arguably a special input form
so question mark is and I mean ampersand
this is an operator yeah okay not so
altered and that's rested do not get
rocked but ones with a built-in me do
better off - I agree with that right I
mean there there are a few cool so if
you go and look at my list are a few
sort of okay I would like to argue these
special input forms like a hash sign
should get a raft although let's not
worry about it for this version well
that's potentially a lot of pop ups
right thinking you have a lot of them in
close succession yeah that's not good
but it'd be nice if somehow you could
tell what is that thing you know you see
in a piece of code and it's like what is
that thing well you can always select it
and hit a fun or you can you know f1 has
been more become more and more difficult
to hit like on my Mac keep
I barely know how to hit f1 most times I
hit f1 it makes my screen go demo oh
that's because you need to go into
settings to tell the Mac that you want
the F keys to actually be F keys because
by default they think that the F keys
should be overloaded as the dim and
perfectly useful but I disagree but
anyway right there that the other I
actually have the opposite problem where
I accidentally hit f1 or some other key
that pops up the help when I didn't
actually want by the way the startup of
the help is awfully slow in the 12:1
that I have right now is that about to
get better so well there are lots of
dependencies around it's difficult to
give an a complete answer to that
succinctly there's there some things I
know about okay I mean I think it's an
important thing to QA to be looking at I
think there's a problem well so I mean
one of the big issues I know is that
there are issues around kernel startup
that are that when you first start the
product you know that can be problematic
okay and that's not my list okay let's
go on here so I I'm I'm good okay so can
we fly so chemica making help special
input forms are a separate issue to be
discussed in another time okay I agree
with these principles otherwise and can
we just quickly look I mean there are a
couple of ones I put question marks in
my to groupings thereof probably
worthwhile and yeah you were there that
the coop closed sections so probably
worth while and probably not worthwhile
look upon me not worthwhile first
I'm thinking here rule delayed is a
possibility what do you think oh you
think it's too horrifying to have it I
mean I think people type in ruled
delayed significantly less often than
ruled so in that sense it's probably not
completely horrifying but it does seem
weird to do one and not the other if
this all of the operators these are the
ones that are currently arrested because
we need to specifically list them to you
notice I'm coming like this this
discrete ratio operator we absolutely
should rock that because nobody yes and
that isn't the worthwhile list okay fine
so so alright so if I went through the I
haven't gone through this table and as I
basically just sort of brainstormed
which ones I I didn't see in in Tom's
list right so Tom came up with a list I
have reviewed it and splitted into these
sections it went through the Unicode
table and I have in my probably
worthwhile and probably not worthwhile
sort of I think all of the Unicode
operators which which have a built-in
meaning right for all and and there
exists are sort of I have them as
probably worthwhile but with a question
mark because on the one wrong I might
have forgotten that guy it's it's there
if you look in my list
so can we scroll up to my list right
okay okay
what is permutation product it's how you
combine permutation I don't know what it
is oh it looks like a circle dot oh my
gosh robbed it exactly salute
robbed it how could we not rough that
okay limit yeah you gotta laugh that I
think mmm-hmm absolutely love these
they're incomprehensible yeah
are we resting carrot for power no we're
not yeah
I was just asking because I think that's
one of those ones that different
languages have different syntax for that
and so it may well I agree that that's
true but I also think that most
languages tend to standardize on carrot
not all of them you're right but I think
most of the deal okay I've got a crazy
idea for you mm-hmm slow rocks if you
hang around long enough around a carrot
it brings up a raft doesn't seem very
useful right the probability that you
would do that seems no because because
you don't see a raft right what do you
do when you don't see a rock I claim you
don't see a raft you stay there
waiting to see if a raft is gonna come
up that's what I would do at least no I
would jiggle to go where the heck is my
raft oh my god that has evolved that I'm
pretty sure we removed it maybe maybe
there's a bill tissue or it shouldn't
have revolved yeah how does the wait for
a raft interact with what I assume is a
preference for a default time to wait
for a raft that I usually set to two
seconds or something it's it's the same
so the same thing that's used for the
function tooltips is the same delay
that's used for function tooltips is
used for the operator s right so my
point is that having a having us
second-class rafts with the delay is
that on top of that initial delay or
is that overriding that initial delay on
top of it an extra second the next half
second so we my proposal I think it's a
look okay the hit rate for people who
are confused is not going to be a
hundred percent but reducing confusion
you know having a a 30 percent
probability of reducing confusion is
still worthwhile so I will be my
suggestion is a slow raft mechanism that
um a secondary raft mechanism for some
of these other things that we think are
too common um this one person a live
stream this is supporting slow raft good
so it's the ref location on that carrot
correct no long absolutely should not be
over printing the thing so there's a
cube root character raft it okay even
though it's standard mathematical
notation but people are not going to
know that you could type it as a single
as a single function great for all and
there exists they're not that common and
people who are you know if if you're a
you know if you're a quantifier pooh-bah
you're going to know what they are but
if you see it in a piece of code you
have no idea why there's an upside down
you know backwards II think okay heck
yes for divisible absolutely you're
never going to know what it is otherwise
yes for cross for sure the x character I
don't think should be rafted except
maybe a slow raft and I think everything
can have us well yeah I think everything
could have a slow enough loft he says um
okay in fashion K absolutely these weird
things absolutely because nobody will
have any idea what they are otherwise
directed edge and undirected edge
absolutely conditioned absolutely
distributed absolutely function
absolutely right so we have these weird
transpose characters which are sort of
you don't
superscript them because there they were
me that pre-scripted
right there born superscripted yeah
exactly and there they're kind of funky
but on the other hand there they're not
used very often so maybe we should just
do that why not what would I mean
especially because I think there's
different conventions I'm like what star
means that's yeah star is the base is
the best one and also dagger sometimes
we should absolutely rock I'm see any
reason not to
okay well just because I think we should
probably make them go away and come up
with a better solution but be that as it
may
somebody who recently joined our live
stream is asking what is rafting okay we
could have explained that but where can
we find one that it's rafted that's
otherwise it involves a river with lots
of whitewater yeah it's putting up this
thing that isn't attached I don't know
why we started calling the rafts I'm
sure that was my name for them it was
your name for the minutes yes and when I
first heard of operator rafts at I asked
the exact same question so what the heck
is an operator raft so right um but just
you you didn't opine on partial D so
that that's I don't say yes why not are
they
yeah I'm again people don't know how to
type it all right look I think there are
two reasons to have these one I mean the
number one reason to have them is their
parent code that you were given and you
have no idea what they are right I'm
sorry good is star carrot considered an
operator and if not how does it get a
raft it should get a raft if we can give
it a raft it's a special input form I'm
sure exactly that on wedge wedge should
get rocks yeah and it's not considered
an operator to answer your question it's
not clear what's wrong could say
yeah I mean it's gonna have to be a
special rock like the like the slash
slash one right and if you unform at
that cell I think we'll see that's all a
single token oops yeah yeah so the front
end doesn't even consider it a separate
token much less an operator okay that's
a separate project for another day um I
mean honestly we should I think we
should you know percent would be an
interesting one I think this where are
the input forms / special input force
where's the detected star watch me not
beyond the page reveal because no no
it's not an operator right it's part of
a number and there's my recollection is
there's an entirely separate page
specifically about numbers which means
that things like um precision marks
should get should get rafts one day as
well okay look we've got several messes
here
okay so first point is these special
input forms should get rafts um but
we're not going to be able to do that
yet
second point complaints on the
livestream that are very valid about how
do you get to I mean the tutorial about
inputs and tax how do you see the syntax
tables the fact that these syntax tables
were built for the book 30 years ago and
have been I mean like all this stuff is
really pretty useful and we barely
mention it oh boy all this crazy stuff
I mean this this documentation could do
with some modernization at least in its
presentation mm-hmm yeah at least as
part of you know tech notes and whatnot
right they think this is now all one
tutorial which was it was probably like
seven separate tutorials and previous
versions and I see something that's out
of date on there I'm gonna go fix it
right now which the column this thing
yeah there should be a backslash pipe
notation I've added that in a few
different places and I don't know how I
overlooked this one okay all right is
that it for okay we didn't quite finish
here we didn't quite finish these yeah
okay I'd say so oft four times okay I
think some appears rarely enough you
might as well raft it okay similar with
product
I think Union intersection likewise
they're pretty rare let's rock them okay
I I don't see why we shouldn't rock
these ones either floor and ceiling
because they already have a tooltip and
the character evidence and and the
characters right I mean the characters
don't have anything to go to right
because one character is left ceiling
and the other characters right ceiling
right so what you mean if I would know
wait a minute they have something
perfectly good to go to they just go to
ceiling there's nothing wrong with that
okay right but okay yeah well if I saw
that in a piece of code I would be I
wouldn't be confused because I know that
notation but but one would be confused
okay well now here dude hit that with
traditional form
okay so I would remove that I mean how
much of that how much of that are we
doing of traditional form if I do a
Bessel j0x
so basically older well I don't so most
special functions have tooltips both
math special functions if they have a
traditional form they have a tooltip but
why don't we I mean why don't we
modernize and why don't we make all of
them rafts they're not because they're
not rafts
I I don't I know but why why couldn't we
make them you know that asically
functionally rafts so that you can go to
the documentation as well because I mean
saying it's Bessel J is useful but it's
even more useful if you can find out
documentation about Bessel J mm I would
have to think about how to evolve that
is right because all that's there is a
template box right there's there are no
operators there right there all there is
is a template box and an X the j-20 and
the parens don't appear well unless
unless the traditional form formats are
tagged it somehow as you say you'd need
some raft equivalent of tooltip or
something yeah John do you've obviously
tagged it to get that tooltip right
[Music]
sorry I was a little distracted you're
trying to right so we have right we have
lots of traditional forms which are
which are which are template boxes with
tooltips and Steven is asking can we
somehow promote those tooltips to rafts
really should we don't have a mechanism
for doing that right now we create one
it's not obviously silly
III think that's a desirable thing to do
I don't think we should the fact that
ceiling has a tooltip in traditional
form should prevent us from rafting it
right although I'm not sure you'll be
able to get to the raft because look
well yeah I get what you're saying I
understand what you're saying I
understand I'm saying if for this
version it is a bug that ceiling does
not have a raft it will be okay okay I'm
just saying in the future we should plan
to have a raft for all of these okay
then um okay number before we move on
from this topic is that is that what
other time of tool tipping is there in
traditional form because I think we
should be phasing out tool tipping and
phasing in rafts would have a you know
not to move the analogy too far but
which have a paddle as well so that you
can get to the help pages right so if
you if we so there's I think these are
in the aptly named files this tooltip TR
they might be in misc that he are but
here I can but I'll you know a lot of
them are our you know traditional form
of functions of math Massey functions
are you sending me a link right so here
maybe the easiest thing would be well
well this work if I take
what are you doing am I about to get
something here the various other
comments on our live stream I want to
look at here there is people complaining
about the operator input forum page not
being accessible yes yes yes
being able to star favorite
documentation pages we're hearing your
mouse grind
you
I don't know about favoriting
pagers I mean I think we've had schemes
for doing that in the past which have
not been very popular
be perfectly honest what I would like is
be to be able to favorite certain
notebooks so that they always appear in
my recent recent notebook open recent
list is possible there just isn't a good
interface for it
oh then we should talk after this
meeting because I don't know how to do
that I don't know how to do it either
okay so that's a UX problem let's maybe
we can discuss that well we're not gonna
get to it here but but maybe we can
discuss it in the user assistance
meeting yeah I mean it's not
particularly high priority compared to
the other things we're dealing with but
I know that but it may be easy if you've
already got the mechanism and there's a
simple UX then even they just put
something in chat which hopefully will
open the list for you and yeah I just
scanned that after opening it and it's I
mean the overwhelming majority are so
you see it's the name of the resource
and so you know and with the tooltip so
these are probably what I use cut copy
undo what the heck are those to be
honest I Oh we'd have to look through
you know probably there's some you know
some you you know some interface
somewhere this is some of this like
current memory usage but these are these
are tooltips for system information
right and I thought they were things
like I would have thought that one was
from the Mac 398 other things in there
too
I mean I see some stuff from the toolbar
and right so this is the template box
tooltips are the ones that sort of are
most directly relevant to typeset who's
been maintaining this stuff me and Lou
and you know probably originally Maxime
and since he left me and Lou and as you
can see these are almost all mathy
special functions if not all methi's
special functions well there are things
that have special input forms like mod
for example
Oh Maude has a special input formed
special I'm sorry special traditional
form for right right yes that's that's
what I mean
so yes these are all you know math what
is Pauline log 3 probably it's the 3
argument form as opposed to the two
arguments as it'll be a different
structure of boxes ok well that looks
harmless enough I mean whether there's
more that should be rafted and input in
in traditional form I'm not sure but
this certainly looks perfectly
reasonable mm-hmm um okay people asking
about the precedence table wise and
precedents documented why isn't the
function precedence documented probably
was it doesn't do what you think it
would do yeah I think we we started
something to sort of tweak it a bit and
document it and is there a documentation
page for it I don't think so it maybe
there's an internal one I I think it is
more horrifying than you can possibly
imagine I mean because it really gets
into the nitty-gritty of the numerical
precedence levels for everything so yes
there is an internal one that we haven't
leaked out and one of the big issues
would be a fairly direct collision
between the front ends notion of
precedence in the colonel's notion of
precedence the I mean we'd have to have
some way to unify changes across both
platforms that would be very not easy
and there's there's a lot of crazy stuff
here why does that say presidents level
n and if I go to the president's forum
page oh my gosh just it just crashed
well that was the prototype build so I
suppose it's that's what I get
oh great it's crashing repeatedly on
startup see if it makes it okay to try
that well we made it okay
um what was I looking at I was looking
at the precedents forum page which
looked to me like it didn't document the
precedents forum right and I would
really love it if we had autocomplete up
their own oh there we go operated with
presidents Prak Peck must be an integer
see notes for infix right which that was
one of horrifying right I mean we looked
at this a couple of years ago and we
planned some improvements and I started
working at them and then I was
interrupted and I yeah right so I mean I
think well I think I should circle back
to it to at least finish the things I
put effort in so that effort isn't
completely wasted even if I don't get it
as perfectly you know to the level I
would want to get it to but it'll still
be better I mean this whole business I'm
gonna tell my story about SMP and it's
it's user-defined syntax which you've
all heard I'm sure you all heard that
story I have anybody else heard that
story there's more than one person who
said it I won't tell it again but but in
SMP we had this lovely idea I think it
was colon colon equals was a way of
defining syntaxes and all went fine well
sort of fine until some user defined a
syntax for you and they had things like
AUB meaning Union I should that user
might have been me I can't even remember
but but um the problem is that then
every time the character you appeared in
anything
it turned it into Union but even the
thing that did I think it was you know
some unset syntax function contained the
caret ceases so there you were without
without any kind of no paddles for them
no paddles
it was a disaster you simply had to
restart I mean there was nothing else to
do there um so that's my bad experience
with use it and also honestly it's so
tricky to get syntax right and not get
confused it's just not something people
you know should be doing there you know
unless they write a whole other grammar
which is a completely different project
but that's a different thing um Karl is
commenting about how modernization of
the docks that were lost touch for
version six that maybe we should let you
guys join in this we haven't half an
hour we have our monthly documentation
status meeting people are interested
maybe we should live stream that I don't
see why we shouldn't since you guys seem
interested in documentation let's plan
that why not um let's just let me send
mail to see if that can happen um okay
let's try and quickly just take I think
we I think I think we should do to the
brand that we think we should do random
generator state and then we should save
the next two for our next meeting
because they're both sort of oh yeah
this is the idea from sander um life see
Mia yes that is my that's my position so
we'll discuss it right it does some good
things yeah and this is another I think
this is also a function from sander okay
okay let's look at your random state
what should block random do when a
stateless method is active right so
normally if you block random you do
whatever and then you're back at the
same state you were before but if it's a
if it's a stateless method like you mean
like hardware random numbers or
something right or OpenSSL right there
why is that one stateless because I
believe because it refuses to give us
the state because then we could crack
people skis okay um by the way did
somebody respond about the
capitalization of blobs
I think they've not been capitalized
mostly they've mostly been capitalized
every single one I wrote that an initial
right okay okay fine we'll just let's
make sure it's consistent I something
was not being capitalized recently okay
so well what what choice does it have I
mean block rather can't do anything
right I mean I think it's only well it
could issue a warning message and go on
it could issue a message and refuse to
do anything no it should not be that
obnoxious I see no reason I think it's
one of these cases where I could imagine
a message that's off by default
and when we finally get our exception
handling of verbosity system working
better we could put it we could you know
allow people to switch it on but I can't
I just think it's a it's one of those
things that's deeply in the noise okay
let's just say hopefully it's yeah
there's a note about it on the inland
the docs for block random but right so
we'll need to add what is this we
document some values right so so a
random generator state has three sub
values you can request the hash which
would appear in the what is the
happiness that that's the hash of the
state if it maybe maybe should maybe
generator state ref page it'll have more
examples it's it's self future eyes so
you need to and it's not ready to be the
notes might be okay the examples
definitely need to be cleaned up before
I D future eyes it but and that it and
there that's the that's the dollar
variable then there should be a link
there I you random generator state oh
maybe they didn't save that but yeah if
you could and there's also a page for
random generator state okay well that
doesn't mention the sub batteries it
doesn't which of which is why it's a
question of should we document the sub
values and arginines okay but it has
more examples on them right so the foe
and right so we have two fully you know
the ones where we have the full state
information like extended CA and that
they just have a hash which is literally
a hash of internal numbers right the
internal data structures but you can't
reconstruct it from the State House you
can't no well not from the state hash
but it tells it right but it doesn't
cause it's distinct you can tell that
whether the two things are distinct but
you can't reconstruct them exactly
correct and and the you know hiding
inside of it is enough and the object
has inside of it the complete state data
in this case so you can in fact I only
turned so but that's just a way to tell
two of them apart well it's it's
actually more than that it's so if
somebody saves saves that state in a
file and reads it back and modify some
piece of it
the hashes won't match and seed random
will not accept it right so it's a so
it's a checksum okay in sort of more way
than okay so if you scroll down to the
properties then you'll see that there
are basically three kinds of generators
so there's the one then there's the one
with the session only hash which are
right
in the same session you can restore them
because you can use the hash to find the
particular memory location which has the
data but you can't write them to a
notebook and restore them in a later
kernel session and then you have open
SSL where it refuses to give us anything
and and so there's nothing I understand
so - so hash the hash sub value gives
you the what is it is a string or is it
a number it's a number I think it's a
number it's it's the result of it's a
result of hash fine ok we make it a
display no no no no it's fine it's a
number that's what we're doing this the
results of hash is a number and we're
fine with that
okay um right okay hold on hold on I'm
just thinking about these names okay
method that's fine hmm I don't know why
we don't call the state hash I think
calling it hash is a bit confusing
especially since it's called state hash
here okay and see realized it seems
wrong it's serializable isn't it that
that would have been my preference by
the you know until we decided to
document that I wasn't going to argue
with Rob well when you have that
straight expression it has it either has
been serialized or it has not so it's a
done deal
that's it whether it's serializable is a
function okay now know what the question
of serializability is I mean what is the
user level way of explaining
serializability it's whether you can
save it or not yep right so we could
call it well it's a horrible name but
survives quit um you know what I'm Aly
on our live stream is asking about the
status of our discussion about the read
mine items and I also I'm confused that
is not on my calendar maybe somebody
could
the Devon could you message people and
see if I can get an answer to when when
that's happening yeah but as - I mean if
serializable I'm fine with that - no but
I don't like that name because I don't
think that's a user level name I mean
what does it mean to a user that it is
serializable it means you can store it
in a file now is that the main thing it
means or is this basically yes okay so
how does that dovetail with our little
what are we going to call it a little
little tab at the bottom of you know an
audio object or something that says you
know save in what am i trying to say
right so we have we have a store now
right so like if you do a large a large
sparse array right so if you do a sparse
array of range of I know 10 to the 5th
or something which is not very sparse
but it'll right it'll say data not in
the notebook store now so we could call
it storable yeah because it is obviously
storable in memory right um we could
call it file storable or notebook
storable fast or bowl is more correct
you you you could also
notebook storable is a non-trivial fact
too because if you reopen this notebook
this random generator state if it is one
of these ones that is serializable is
there correctly where as a business or
so it's not there correctly not please
sorry I interrupted you no that's okay I
was just thinking if it's useful to
think of it in the opposite sort of way
you know that's temporary isn't there
quite the right word here but if session
only or yeah
I like it I'm not sure we should do it
but I liked the suggestion vegetable is
amusing session local
mmm-hmm because OpenSSL is session
fashion well the other thing we call it
is something like persistence and then
we could call it either session session
only is at least clear I mean really
what it is is we could call it
restorable I think that's very hard to
understand out of context mm-hmm make
persistent no it's not making persistent
you can't do anything with it I mean the
problem is that blind on a live stream
is saying it see realized as false what
do you do well the answer is you're out
of luck right it's so-so
so basically what and so the answer to
that question is if you're still in the
same session then it will find it and it
will use it and if you're not in the
same session it will give you a message
and saying well it can't fully restore
the state so it's going to use the
method information that's in write
object assuming it's valid but use a new
state this is cross session
I mean persistence really
um barb is asking why we can't use our
own thesaurus and yes I'm just proud of
my my wetware thesaurus being pretty
good too
um we have tried using Mathematica to
create its own function names and with
varying degrees of success meaning space
is a complicated thing which I have
studied quite a bit um you know I have a
tendency to say that we should call this
you know cross session persistent it's
incredibly long and ponderous but it is
fairly clear what it means and I mean
you'll all I mean I can think of an
application for this but right I mean
you see it right there you see its value
right there in the typeset form so it's
only in certain very special
programmatic sessions where you're like
oh I need to protect myself in this
random code in case somebody decided to
be crazy and set you know method so I'm
ok with a long name fine
let's do it cross session persistent
true or false but when it says method
data only what does that mean method
data only it means that there is no
state hash present in this right because
again OpenSSL doesn't give us any state
data ok so ok I thought that is a very
obscure three words in my opinion I
think it should say state hash and we
don't need to say none there why don't
we just say paren not available with
this method ok I was trying to say with
that method data only is that if you use
that as a seed it will change the method
to OpenSSL but it won't do anything else
right doesn't make any I mean so why
don't we just say not paren not
available with this method okay and that
way people are you know that they'll be
yeah that's fine that's fine why it
isn't available you should document in
the you should just say for does not for
security reasons does not allow blah
blah blah
we're not guaranteeing anything is
totally secure but we're tank we're
giving people some reason why that's
happening okay so you can skip this one
because that's a bug that Rob fixed like
half an hour after I created this agenda
and then right so if you save the state
in the variable right so if you create
one of these OpenSSL guys and then you
seed random with it then you'll get this
you know this message about well it's
only going to use the state data but if
you saved it in a variable and then you
did seed random with that variable then
that will go oh this is pointer equal to
a pre-existing state and so I'm not
going to issue the message and that
seems weird I don't know it's a how bad
of a bug or how hard it would be well I
think it just is a question of rebooting
the message slightly I mean first of all
this is not acceptable generator method
boy set to whatever the string name is
right um
from this random state expression I know
from the random state expression that's
fine okay um if we said something like
if we just said since it is not in the
same session or something since it does
not come from the current session well
it is in the same session right you know
but but the the the case where it can
restore it is when it has it's still in
memory right no I mean in right that's
this method has no state data right so
you're never restoring it to the same
stage or just restoring it to the method
so in both cases what it effectively did
was the same thing the only difference
is it issued a message in this case
because this was a new and new expert
with the same full form as state where a
state is literally the same expert
actually a various more special case
than that it's it's if if it's only
gonna going to do that without the
message if if the generator has not been
changed in the meantime I mean so I
think this is one of the cases where
give this message but it seems like you
know it's not we're slowing everything
down to do that but let's not let's just
leave this it is weird
put it in possible issues just let me
make sure I understood so Rob you're
saying that if I did state equals seed
random of blah and then I did random
real and then I did seed random of state
I would get a message I believe so yeah
all right then that that makes sense and
all you know if not I'll give you a bug
to fix fine okay good stuff for those on
the live stream we will in fact be
live-streaming our monthly documentation
update
and it will start in about 10 to 15
minutes and thank you all you all soon
bye-bye